sees a wrinkle in time once hi everyone
my name is Tamara chambers and this is
Tamara Jessa and last night I went and
saw a wrinkle in time oh do you see them
right on the horizon unpopular opinions
can you see them they're mine I wrote a
lot of notes for this in the theater
just scrambling things down but the
first one was glitter brows make glitter
brows for the episode so the most
important thing happened at least I grew
up with the book and I remember reading
it in school and being like oh my gosh I
actually liked that it was like an
assigned book that I actually cared
about and actually read all the way
through and I I really enjoyed it I was
very excited to see an adapted though I
don't think that all books necessarily
need a screen adaptation but I was
excited I was on board for this that I
saw the cast and the director and I was
very on board for it and I really
enjoyed it
watching it felt so special felt like
they were doing something in some
aspects that you just don't get I mean
it just all comes down to the diversity
in this film was just really special to
watch there were some problems for sure
some of the costuming choices and some
of just the the practical places they
they filmed I think New Zealand weird it
just looked so so beautiful
there were though some weird wonky odd
awkward special effects and you know it
was kind of hard to miss those moments
for sure I love the people in this film
and think the kids were really cute
though they were a little awkward for me
I wish that the youngest the younger
brother Charles what was his name Manson
I forget it just wish that he had been
cast differently he was not given in
general the kids didn't react to things
like I feel like I was reacting to them
in
Theatre like watching these things
happen like seeing the three women show
up Reese Witherspoon and Mindy and Oprah
in their backyard and and the girl is
just kind of like that's interesting
okay that's not the word I would use but
no one was reacting really the way that
I thought but those were those were my
problems
I thought the acting was a little
awkward some of the dialogue a little
awkward and some weird CGI things but I
left it with so much more than I thought
I was going to leave it with and it felt
so important and it was beautiful and
some really touching moments happened
with the family even though the acting
wasn't stellar the parents I love I love
both of those actors Chris Pine favorite
Chris favorite of all the Chris's and
and the wife too I love her so much and
and some of the family moments that they
had were really really beautiful really
well put together and touching and I
cried for sure I think though the
biggest thing that this film is gonna
suffer from is hype because you you make
a film with a very diverse cast and it
gets a lot of hype because of that
because there's not a lot of those films
and then if it's not perfect people just
really harp on it I think that this is a
film that that kids can see I was
watching it and I would critique
something in my mind and then I'd be
like oh right this is a movie for kids
this is meant for all ages of course but
especially children Chris Pine
disappears and it's the family kind of
picking up the pieces trying to live
their lives try to find out where he
went but overall just kind of move on
because it's been four years and he
disappeared in a science experiment
which is a fun plot to go off of and he
find out through these three amazing
characters Reese Witherspoon Oprah and
Mindy Kaling that he has like time
hopped I forget what they call it in
this
Church or muggles Mindy's first seen and
Reese Witherspoon's first seen we're
just a bit wonky a bit weird I didn't
think that Reese Witherspoon's comedy
that she had written in really landed
same with Mindy I think they're both are
really wonderful actresses but like
there's a few times where Mindy said
there was one where she speaks in quotes
from different people and one of the
quotes was just damn and it didn't
really play well and I couldn't I see
what they were going for I see how it
could have worked but it just I don't
know I don't think they got the right
take and then they used it and it was
just it was a little weird
then Oprah shows a giant billboard size
to Oprah which I'm all about the
weirdest thing is that the boy who's
just kind of like along for the ride he
shows up he has a crush on the lead
character and he's just kind of like
yeah I'm down for this I'll do this cool
and like doesn't really react to
anything which is so odd to me because a
lot of crazy things are happening but
then I realized I mean maybe that's just
they're going for childhood innocence
maybe he's just like everything's
possible so yeah I will say yes and to
this and to go along with it maybe it
just didn't read super well for me
Brooke this about the kids the lead and
the awkward boy it's like imagine
finding your soul mate in middle school
can you imagine that I read three
hundred and fifty-seven books my seventh
grade year and I read three hundred and
ninety-two books my eighth grade year so
I for sure had friends definitely wasn't
meeting and he's told me I did have my
first boyfriend in junior high and we
held hands that I felt very
uncomfortable so I broke up with him
it's just a self-help movie I feel like
I feel like this entire film is just a
giant self-help film where you watch it
and you take things and you learn
lessons and it's just very like oh I
feel good now that's what this film is
Oprah says do you realize the amount of
events and occurrences that had to occur
to lead to the making of you just the
way you are and it was beautiful it was
just so good mmm
I loved it because it's full of people
that I want to see on screen more it's
late it's a woman taking the lead in a
film that's not a chick flick and you
know we are getting more of those now
and it's really fun like Wonder Woman is
some yeah I mean I just sat there with
my jaw open for the whole time this is
one that's geared towards children and I
think that's so flippin cool and so
important to have it's like it's just a
big adventure that they go on to find
the father and the girl is leading
around the guy and the guys kind of
following and he trips and he messes
things up and she has to take care of
him and the gender swapping of that is
really exciting you you know you usually
get the girl who's like following around
and it's like a nuisance kind of it it's
nice it's fun to see that it's nice to
have both of those options you know what
I mean it's exciting at the end of the
day this is a really cool book that I
loved growing up it's about a mixed
family with an adopted son and a
daughter and it's full of love and
science and adventure and it's an
awesome kids film it's because of the
hype but I feel like people are
criticizing this like it's the next like
I don't know Citizen Kane which I've not
seen it's a really kick-ass like quirky
sometimes awkward kids movie I loved it
it was good talk to you a lesson
there weren't fart jokes in it yes I
wrote if you don't like this I
understand there were some weird moments
I don't think a lot of people are gonna
like this I I don't I don't I don't know
that like like the Walker brothers I
don't think they're gonna love this film
and and I think I I completely
understand I shouldn't say that I don't
know what they're gonna like jeez I
wasn't like coming for him
I just say I don't think a lot of
reviewers are going to like that movie
is what I should say and I understand
why there were some weird things
happening in some weird moments just odd
CGI and weird story of stuff and if for
a movie to have so many problems and for
it to still impact me so much I think
that means that it still it's an
important film especially for children
it like I said it's just a giant
self-help
movie I will watch this again when I'm
feeling sad I I loved it I also think
it's really cool for fans of the book I
got this message from my dad last night
and it was after I saw the film and it
just made me smile so much he said so
when I was in the fifth / sixth grade I
didn't really like reading but one day I
checked out a book from the library
titled a wrinkle in time it was the
first book I ever read cover to cover
and I loved it
they made a movie about it and it wasn't
good at all but this one looks like they
actually read the book and made the
movie can't wait to see it I just think
that's so cool I'm curious to see what
people who love the book think I'm
curious to see how kids react to this
I'm curious to see what this movie does
how it does in like 10 years is this
gonna be something that like people who
were kids now are going to be like I
loved that film or is it just gonna
disappear into the nothingness of space
like all bad movies do I loved it
I recommend seeing it and I hope that
you can find something good to take out
of it as well I know there's problems I
know that I know that I still really
enjoyed it so I recommend seeing it
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you all next week
you
[Music]